While Disney movies may be made for kids,
they are also made by adults and the adults
behind these movies have been known to hide
secret messages and adult jokes in almost
all of their films.
For this list, we are taking a look at some
mature Disney movie moments that kids probably
didn’t catch.
Here are 10 Adult Moments That Disney Snuck
Into Kids Movies.
Enjoy this video then be sure to subscribe
to our channel and join the notification squad
to get your hands on brand new Screen Rant
videos every day of the week!
Monsters Inc.
In a moment when Sully is entering a child’s
room to give them a scare, there is a very
adult drawing that we definitely hope kids
didn’t catch.
Looking at the drawing on the left hand side,
Monsters Inc. is not as innocent as it seems
as it looks like the kid has drawn her mother
in a pretty compromising position with someone
named “Uncle Roger”.
Not only is this drawing shockingly dirty,
it also might be uncovering a scandalous story
of adultery.
This is one of the more R-Rated Disney moments
we have ever seen, but you have to have a
good eye to catch it!
Lion King
It’s no secret that The Lion King is one
of the best movies that Disney has ever made,
but what is surprising is how many dirty jokes
are actually hidden in the film.
It’s hard to pick just one, so here’s
a few!
First off, the poster/DVD cover for film looks
a heck of a lot like the backside of a woman
in a bikini.
Next, there is the famous moment when Simba
blows dust into the air and if you pause at
right time, the dust spells out sex.
There is also the oddly sexual moment between
Nala and Simba in the jungle that definitely
caught some viewers off guard.
All in all, Lion King may just be the ruler
of the adult jokes hidden in Disney films.
A Bug’s Life
A Bug’s Life is one of Disney Pixar’s
oldest movies, but that doesn’t mean it
isn’t just as good as the newer films.
Along with quality storytelling and some fun
characters, the movie also showcases Pixar’s
famous talent for slipping adult jokes into
their kid’s films.
In one scene from the movie, a bunch of bugs
are gathered to watch girl bugs perform.
One of the raunchier bugs yells out from the
audience yells out to the girl on stage, saying:
“Hey cutie, wanna pollinate with a real
bug?”
Pollinate, of course, means to fertilize,
so it’s pretty easy to understand what the
catcalling bug was getting at here.
The Santa Clause
Disney has made a lot of Christmas movies
over the years and one of the best ones has
to be 1994’s The Santa Clause.
Near the start of the movie, Charlie is watching
his dad fly off the roof and remarks, “You’re
flying!”
Without missing a beat, Tim Allen’s Santa
responds that he is used to flying as he lived
through the sixties.
This is clearly a reference to the drug filled
decade that was the 60’s and it is definitely
a joke that most kids would have totally missed.
We’re guessing that more than a few parents,
who may or may not have been flying themselves
in the sixties, enjoyed this sneaky joke!
The Emperors New Groove
Kronk is probably the best part of The Emperor’s
New Groove so it only makes sense that he
was at the center of the film’s most cleverly
placed adult joke.
When we see Kronk out camping in a tent that
was so small, it’s easy to just brush this
off as a joke about his size.
But, once you realize that the tent is strategically
placed over his crotch, it becomes pretty
clear that Disney is playing off the idea
of men “pitching a tent” in bed.
This is one of the studios cleverest mature
moments and we have to give them full points
for execution!
Cars 2
While Cars 2 may have not been anywhere near
as good as the original movie, it did give
the world one of the sneakiest and most risqué
dirty Disney jokes of all time.
In one particular scene from the film, the
cars are having a party.
What kind of party?
Well, a lemon party, of course!
If you aren’t sure why that is included
on our list of adult jokes, that’s probably
for the best as Lemon Party is one thing that
you should never Google.
Peter Pan
Peter Pan is a classic Disney movie and follows
the story of a young flying boy who never
wants to grow up.
Well, it turns out that the movie actually
featured a pretty adult moment that you definitely
had to be grown up to catch.
Near the beginning of the film, Peter is dancing
around in front of his shadow and if you pause
the movie at right time you can see that his
shadow has his…uhm…”peter” hanging
out.
It’s a very quick moment that we’re guessing
slipped by most kids but when you look back
at it, it’s quite shocking!
Zootopia
While it can be argued that Disney’s 2016
movie, Zootopia, is really just an adult movie
in disguise, the majority of the content in
the film is kid friendly.
That being said, there are a few moments that
are definitely aimed at older audiences.
For example, in one scene between Judy Hopps
and Nick Wilde, Hopps makes a joke about how
bunnies are great at multiplication.
While kids may have thought this was just
a random math joke, adults in the audience
will know that the young bunny is making a
reference to the promiscuous nature of her
species.
The Incredibles
The Incredibles is a pretty great movie and
a safe bet for parents to pop on the TV for
their kids without having to worry.
That being said, there is one mature moment
that may have caught some older viewers off
guard.
When Mr. Incredible and Elastigirl first meet,
there is definitely some sexual tension between
the two heroes.
What starts out as friendly chatter easily
escalates to a more flirtatious encounter.
A very suggestive line about what Elastigirl
can do with her flexibility caps off this
scene.
Most kids probably just thought she was talking
about gymnastics, but we are guessing the
adults in the room had other ideas.
Ratatouille
When it comes to great Disney movies, Ratatouille
is often over looked.
It really shouldn’t be as it tells a really
great story and even manages to sneak it some
pretty fun adult jokes.
There’s a scene in which Linguini is trying
to confess to Colette that he’s been getting
assistance from Remy the rat, and he reluctantly
says, “I have this tiny, little, little…”
The words "tiny" and "little" prompt Colette
to quickly glance down at Linguini’s junk
with concern, and he instantly is worried
that she thinks he has a small package.
In the end, Colette and Linguini seem to get
along just fine, so it looks like there was
no cause for concern after all.
So there you have it, there is our list of
10 adult moments that Disney snuck into kid’s
movies.
Which one of these mature jokes was your favorite?
What other dirty Disney moments have you caught
on to?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments
below!
Don’t forget to subscribe to our channel
and join the notification squad so you don’t
miss our latest and greatest new videos!